former democratic senator al franken
appeared on cnn alongside republican
strategist alice stewart to talk about
the supreme court's decision to overturn
roe v wade in the political orientation
of the court and i have not seen
anything like this in a very long time
al franken turned alice stewart into a
sputtering mess over the issue of
republicans holding up nominations
including that of merrick garland and it
is it's truly a pleasure to watch and
you know one of the things we've been
talking about on the show is democrats
need to be on the offensive gavin
newsome said democrats need to be
ruthless and i completely agree
we need more like this because when you
actually don't allow them to squirm away
from direct questions like when else was
this strategy used to deny nominees a
hearing
other than for merrick garland
alice stewart completely implodes this
is so well done take a look a week
before the election
that destroyed the legitimacy of the
court
alice what do you think did chief
justice roberts sort of
i mean he sort of
ignored some of what al is talking about
there and that there is i mean
a tremendous amount of controversy
as to how this court got tilted in the
direction of the far right just to
throw a little accuracy and some of what
what al said there look the the merrick
garland
was held up because we had a divided
government we had a democrat in the
white house and we had republicans in
control of that's not what was said
that's not what mcconnell said
but
but that's the way
historically this has been when you're
in close to an election year and you
have divided government
historically yes when you have divided
government there typically is uh now
you'll actually see the moment she
starts sputtering inclination to tell me
when this happened before
when you when you close to another
when you're well merrick garland is
certainly one when there's a divided
government no before
they're moving they're not moving
forward tell me when this happened
before uh al i'm telling you this is
what the
uh
tell me what happened before
i can't this is what happened
historically tell me when it happened
before look this is the way that the
republicans
went
like i can't give you an exact example
of when this happened
because it hadn't happened before
look
the basis for not appointing him was
because of that specific reason but no
it wasn't and mcconnell's explicitly
said that it was the quote biden rule
and he quoted a little piece of of a
speech that biden had given
in june
of 80
and
he did biden said they wouldn't take up
if they weren't consulted and if
and this was about someone resigning in
june
after a term of the court which is very
different than someone dying
scalia died in february
and you saw
you guys if you can find the tape you
can find
lindsey graham saying
i
keep the tape
we will not take up
a judge of if someone dies a
a a nominee if someone dies an election
year in the next
in the next election
this this is total hypocrisy and you
actually i i'm surprised
that you're claiming this and you can't
come up with an example because there is
none
look
to get back to the point of the cause no
but this is the
this is the point that's exactly right
we're talking about kamala harris and
her calling kamala the current uh
supreme court justices activist justices
because she doesn't like the outcome of
their ruling and when they're made their
decisions yeah and of course the point
here is how did this court even become
what it is
um i think that to some degree
this is what democrats need to do every
time republicans lie
call them out shame them continue to
expose that they are lying now why was
that why did this even happen you have
to understand right
it's because jim acosta allowed it to
happen
in many other settings
the anchor or the interviewer will will
prevent this from happening either
uh
for reasons of time and formatting or
because they want to bail out one side
jim acosta at any point could have
jumped in and saved alice stewart she
didn't deserve to be saved and it's a
good thing that jim acosta didn't she
was lying and the other person she's
arguing against called her out for her
lies and it was silly to think that you
were going to be able to get away with
that with someone like al franken al
franken identified the silly game and he
called it out
now
this is representative of a bigger issue
with the republican party right now
they have zero integrity in politics
if there is no precedent or a rule that
says you can't do something they will do
it and then they will say that's the
precedent i mean think of the
i want to stop short of calling it evil
genius because it's it's these things
aren't really that smart they work
because the system tolerates them and
the people tolerate them and maybe maybe
we shouldn't but the the idea here is
she says
okay well we did this thing with merrick
garland and al franken says but what's
the precedent for that and she says well
it happened with garland right no but
what's the precedent at that point what
was the precedent
we did it with garland no but that
garland can't be the precedent for
garland it's all so stupid and it's such
a base and fundamentally vapid
uh uh
sort of framing of the debate
but when they're allowed to get away
with it of course they're going to
continue doing it and you know to go
back to the al franken thing we've
talked about this before al franken did
engage in a very distasteful joke you
know this photograph uh that that
led to his eventual resignation from the
uh from the senate um i i do think
democrats were a little quick in order
to show their
lack of hypocrisy in demanding that
franken resign when compared to so many
other things that have happened for
which no one has resigned
it was so
minor
and we've talked to democrats who say
yeah it was it was actually a little bit
jumping the gun on demanding frank and
resign just to show how non-hypocritical
we are
franken is really good at this and
absolutely humiliating there for alice
stewart
your internet provider websites you
visit social media companies they all
follow you around online and profit from
selling your data anyone can piece
together this data about you it's quite
disturbing the solution is make yourself
anonymous with private internet access
our sponsor private internet access has
gone further than any other vpn to
demonstrate their commitment to your
privacy they don't collect or store any
data about user activity they've proven
this in court multiple times their
software is one hundred percent open
source so you can see
that no data is being logged everybody
should be using a vpn for your research
on which vpn is most trustworthy i think
you'll land where i did private internet
access it's great for streaming they
have 24 7 customer support they have a
30 day money back guarantee if you don't
love it you can choose from ip addresses
in 84 countries and all 50 u.s states
and my audience gets percent off so you
can stay protected for just two dollars
and eleven cents a month plus you'll get
three months free go to private internet
access dot com slash pacman the link is
down below